Narrator: These moldy car floors,
seats caked with debris,
and crusty cup holders
are in need of a proper clean.
We asked detailers to
share the filthiest cars
they have ever worked on.
They show us how a simple deep clean
can transform even the
most forgotten vehicles.
To kick us off,
we'll follow Elizabeth
Renevier of Mo3 Detailing.
She shares how to make
stained car interiors
look brand new.
My name is Elizabeth Renevier.
I am the owner and
operator of Mo3 Detailing.
Afterwards, I put on a pretreatment,
and I let it sit for
about 10 to 15 minutes.
And then I agitate with a drill brush
or a hard-bristle brush.
So, for the floor mats,
I like to hang them up
and rinse them out really well,
because those can just be
filled with sand and dirt.
All that really gets deep into the fibers,
and just vacuuming isn't enough.
Narrator: Next up, Brent
Dicesare from WD Detailing
cleans the smelliest car
he has ever worked on.
My name is Brent Dicesare.
I'm one half of WD Detailing.
And today, we're going to be cleaning
an extremely dirty car that used to belong
to a hoarder who's now in treatment.
When we first got this car,
we actually had to leave
it outside of our shop
for over a week just to let it air out,
because it was one of the
worst-smelling vehicles
that we've ever been brought,
only because there was
so much grime and grease
in both the carpets and the seats
and there was just a ton
of garbage everywhere.
When we opened the
doors, I started gagging.
We both had respirators on.
We couldn't do it without it.
The first thing we did
was use the ozone machine.
The ozone machine removes
air pollutants and odors
while also killing bacteria
and viruses inside the car,
which makes it a lot safer
for us to work in there.
After taking the seats out,
the first thing that we do
is take all the trash out
and completely vacuum the car.
That way we can really see
what we're working with.
So, when you see a car in this condition,
it doesn't always make
too much sense to save it,
but this car was brought to us
by a really, really nice
gentleman named Parker.
He reached out to us and told us
that he wanted to clean the car
and give it away to someone
who really needed it.
That really touched us,
so we were instantly in.
As we were vacuuming, we
found a pile of dead bugs
that were just sitting on the carpet
right next to the back seat,
and it was mixed in
with some hair and just
some of the goodies when
you're detailing disaster cars.
When people leave food
or anything of that sort
that starts breaking down,
that's when the maggots start
appearing in their cars.
They vacuum up pretty easily,
as long as they don't
splatter all over the carpet.
But even then, you can just extract them.
This garbage was so stuck on,
we literally could not
get it off with our hands.
Even a power washer isn't
good enough to get it off.
So we'll use a flathead
screwdriver occasionally.
That helps get stuff off of the surface
that we otherwise wouldn't be able to.
It actually wasn't sticky or oily.
It was kind of like a
rough feeling, like Velcro.
It's almost like that rough feeling.
That's how bad this carpet was.
If we didn't pull the
carpet out of this car,
there was no possible way
we were going to get it completely clean,
especially with all the stains on it.
You would normally want
to replace this carpet,
but we were trying to keep the budget
as low as possible, as per Parker.
That's what he wanted to do.
So the original color of this car's
carpets, floor mats, seats was a gray.
And when we got it,
they were almost black.
The stains in the carpet came from ...
I don't even know, honestly.
We were just assuming that it's, like,
grease and dirt and
everything mixed together.
We have this carpet brush
that will get any hairs out of the carpet,
because this carpet also had
what seemed like dog hair in it as well,
and we got all that out
with a vacuum and our brush.
We used a degreaser instead
of an extractor soap,
only because degreaser is a bit stronger.
And then we went ahead
and drill-brushed it in
to start getting it to work into
the fibers of the carpet.
We ended up having to power wash
and extract this carpet four times.
After you spend 20
minutes on the same stain
or half an hour and keep working at it
and you can tell that
it's not changing color,
it's not coming out anymore,
and there's really not
that much more you can do,
you know as a detailer it's
kind of time to just call it.
I would say 85% of the stains
and the dirt were out of the carpet
and about 15% that was
just complete damage
was never going to come out.
We hung it up inside of a closet
where there's a heater.
So we actually had to
let it dry for two days.
So, dyeing the carpet
was actually a last-minute decision
that I ended up making myself.
The first step is to
spray dye on the carpet.
We use a brush to brush it into the carpet
to make sure it doesn't just sit,
'cause if it sits, then the carpet
will become, like, hard, bristly texture.
And then you'll go back
and you'll spray over it again.
And then you just let it sit and dry,
and that's really it.
The only things you
want to be careful about
are inhaling the fumes, so
we wore our respirators.
And because we're in a parking garage,
we have a really big exhaust
fan right next to us,
and we had that running the entire time.
And we don't do this on normal carpets,
or, honestly, ever,
but when we saw that some of the stains
weren't coming out, we wanted to make sure
that this is going to
really change someone's life
and they're going to be
happy when they receive it.
Embedded in the seats are grease.
And there was so much of it,
after we did the entire extraction
the first time, we let it dry overnight,
and we came back the next day,
and it was completely
covered in grease again.
So everything that was farther in the seat
came to the surface.
So we had to clean them a second time.
So, after we spray our extractor soap,
we'll let the soap sit
for about a minute or two,
and then we'll go ahead
and use the drill brush
to agitate the soap into the fibers,
and then we'll clean it
out with the extractor.
The extractor has a little nozzle
that sprays hot water into
the fibers of the seat.
And then it also has a vacuum head.
So as it's spraying the water into it,
it's sucking the water
out at the same time.
That way it can clean it.
We have a clear head on it,
so we can actually see all of the soap,
all of the dirt coming out of the seat.
And when that water coming
through is completely clear,
that's how you know
when the seat is clean.
So, now we're cleaning
the back seat of the car,
which was also one of the
grossest parts of the car.
And the first thing we
did was use the Tornador
to spray off any of the dirt.
And that is simply just
an air-compressor tool
that shoots out air in
a tornado formation.
And that'll get a lot of the dirt
out of the deeper fibers of the seat.
And then after that,
we'll go on to the extracting process.
The Tornador's best for getting
any kind of microparticles
out of the carpet or out of the seats
and then dust or dirt
or anything that's on the
topical layer as well.
So, at this point, we're
taking apart the center console
so we can get it out of the car
and pressure wash all
of the disgusting grease
and mold and everything off of it.
Dirt definitely gets behind both the radio
or any of the knobs on the center console,
because that's where your
hands are touching a lot.
So by dissembling those things
and cleaning behind them,
we know that we're sanitizing
and doing the best job
that we possibly can.
Sometimes the Tornador can't get things
that are super stuck on
if they're gooey or anything like that,
almost like a glue substance to plastics.
The air is not going to
do a good enough job,
so you have to scrape it
off and power wash it.
We wanted to give it a good
exterior cleaning, too.
It did have a thick layer
of dust on the exterior.
The engine bay was dirty.
The wheels had brake dust all over them.
Surprisingly enough,
dirt or dust actually acts
as a protectant to paint.
So when a car is dusty or
covered in a layer of dirt,
it protects it from the sun's UV rays.
So, the first thing that we do is
we spray our degreaser all over the paint,
'cause it's paint-safe,
and that'll just start
loosening up any of the
dirt on the outside.
And then we'll use our power washer
to get the dirt off.
So, after we wash the car,
we go ahead and we spray
the entire thing down
with the ceramic sealant
while it's still wet.
And that just gives it a
little bit of protection
and also a shine after we wash it.
And then we'll go ahead
and spray it down again
before drying it.
After we were done with it,
he actually needed to take
it back to his home shop
and do some mechanical work on it
to make sure it's safe for the people,
whoever owns it next.
We're really happy with
the result of this car,
but what meant the most to
us is how Parker reacted,
because this was something special to him.
And the fact that we
got to be a part of it
is why we did it in the first place.
We do all these details
absolutely for free.
So we took this on because
we wanted to make a change
and we wanted to help a
family that needed it.
Narrator: For this car, Brent
tackles months of mold growth
caused by water damage.
My name's Brent Dicesare,
and I'm half of WD Detailing.
And today we're going to be cleaning
a super-moldy car
that has grass growing in it, mold, water,
and all of the above.
It was absolutely disgusting.
First, we put the ozone
machine inside the car.
It basically pumps oxygen
to the third degree into it,
or ozone,
and it suffocates the
bacteria and kills it.
And then we'll pull the seats out
after we do the ozone treatment,
so we can actually
get to all of the spots that we need to.
And then the first thing
that we'll do is vacuum it,
try to get all the
debris, or, in this case,
the mold and the water out of it
so we can really get in
the car and work on it.
So, here we're working with
where all of the water ended up going.
The water was only on half of the car,
and I think that's because of
where the leak was located.
So what you're looking at right now
is us vacuuming up all of that water.
The last time that this
car was plated was in 2015,
so it ended up sitting
for the last six years.
And just about five months ago,
the owner noticed that there was
an issue with the sunroof
where it wouldn't close all the way
and water was continuously
getting in there,
but we've never seen
anything like this before.
For a car like this,
it's actually recommended
to remove the carpet,
throw it away, and replace it.
But for some reason, in this specific car,
it was stapled down completely
to the point where if we
were going to remove it,
it wasn't going to go back in
and sit the way that it would need to.
For this car,
it was definitely a different process
than when we would normally extract a car,
because the carpet was basically stained
with that green mold.
And we had to try to figure out a way
to push it out of the fibers of the carpet
and see if the carpet would revive
to the white color that it ended up being.
So the first thing that we did,
which we normally would not do,
is use the Tornador attachment,
which is compressed air
that shoots out in a circle,
like a tornado almost.
You have a little compartment
where you put all-purpose cleaner in
mixed with water, so you dilute it,
and you attach it to an air
hose on an air compressor.
And it really gets into
the fibers of that cloth
and kind of blows out anything
that might be in there.
So we blew out the entire carpet with it
after vacuuming it.
And then we'll go ahead
and we'll use our extractor soap on it
and spray a healthy amount on there.
And we'll actually use the extractor,
which shoots hot water into the carpet,
to get the carpet a little bit more wet,
because when we use our drill brush,
we want to try to reduce
the amount of friction
that we're putting into the carpet.
Because if there's too much friction,
if it's not wet enough,
then it can actually damage the carpet.
We'll use our drill brush
to agitate all of that soap.
So we'll go over it a few times,
get it really into the fibers.
And then we'll use our
hot-water extractor,
which only has water in it.
We don't ever recommend
putting any kind of soaps
or anything in your extractor,
because when you're blowing
the water into the carpet,
you want to suck everything out,
and if you have soap in it,
it's just going to add more to it
and it's not going to be completely clean.
I actually filled half of
a Shop-Vac full of water.
So I think I actually got
probably 95% to 99% of the water out.
When you do the doors, it's the same thing
as doing any of the other
plastics in the car.
In this case, we used Triclean,
which is made to kill bacteria
and all that stuff inside of cars.
While most all-purpose
cleaners do kill bacteria,
we wanted something that
is a little bit stronger.
Especially because in this case,
there's a lot more mold
than you would normally
see in a regular car.
And then use the Tornador attachment
or some soft-bristle brushes
and really get in every nook and cranny
and make sure we clean it up.
So, for this part,
he's actually drying off the door
and getting all the liquid
out of the nooks and crannies.
So that is the Tornador attachment,
but that's a different one
than the one that is used
for specifically cleaning.
So this Tornador attachment doesn't have
the canister that holds
any kind of cleaner,
and this one just blows out air.
So you use that to get
into cracks and crevices
where you normally couldn't with a brush
or with a microfiber towel,
or you use it to get under seats.
When we do leather seats
that have been sitting in mold,
the first thing we do
with any seat is vacuum it
just to get any kind of debris.
Especially in the crevice
where the bottom and the
back of the seat meet,
we'll use an all-purpose cleaner
or a leather cleaner.
They're two different things.
A leather cleaner is more suitable
for high-end leather.
And then he'll spray it on there,
use a Colourlock brush.
So it's a really fine, strong brush
to get into all of the pores of the seat.
When we're cleaning leather seats,
we don't use too much pressure
just because you don't
want to damage them.
You could leave scratches,
you could tear them.
Spray it again, use the
steamer to kill any bacteria,
and then wipe that away too.
When we do the wheels, the first thing
we like to do is pressure wash them off
and get any of that initial dirt
or grime off of them.
We have some heavy acid that we'll use
if it's really bad,
but we don't use it on painted rims.
And then we'll go ahead
and we'll agitate it with a brush,
and we'll use a few different brushes
to really get in both the wheel well,
on the tire, inside the rim,
and the drum of the rim.
And then we'll go ahead
and pressure wash it away.
So, for the exterior,
because it had been
sitting out for so long,
over time if you don't clean it,
grime will get attached to the paint
and start growing mold.
Because we did the
exterior of the car first,
we weren't too worried
about water getting in,
since it was already full of water.
So we just went ahead
and we pressure washed everything out.
We put paint-safe degreaser
all over the paint
because it just had a really thick layer
of both mold and grime on it
that wouldn't just come off
with an initial pressure wash.
We let it sit for about
two to three minutes,
and then we pressure washed it again.
And then we'll go ahead and
we'll use the foam cannon.
So, the foam is just a car soap,
and you just put it into a foam cannon
and you attach it to your pressure washer.
It acts as a lubricant for
any dirt that's on the car.
So when you go to wash it,
you're really minimizing
how much scratching can
happen to the paint.
And then we'll go ahead
and we'll use our microfiber mitts
to wash it and then spray it off.
The absolute best way to store a car
if it's going to be outside
is with some sort of car cover or a tarp.
That way, no water is going to get
on the top of the car
and find its way into the car.
It'll keep the paint clean
and away from all the elements.
If it's going to be a car
that you're not driving
for extended periods of time,
you still want to look in it
and make sure nothing's going wrong,
because seals can give.
And if they do and
water starts getting in,
then that's a whole world of problems.
So the best way to stop
mold is to be proactive
and check on your car before
it actually starts growing.
When it comes to detailing,
I believe it's best to
maybe get a full detail
once to twice a year, maybe three times.
I always tell people to vacuum it,
if not every few weeks,
at least once a month.
Narrator: RJ Wagner from WD Detailing
now attempts to revive
this unusually muddy car.
I'm RJ. I'm one half of WD Detailing,
and today we're going to
be showing you how we clean
quite possibly the
muddiest WS6 Firebird ever.
It was involved in a really
bad flood in Kentucky.
The car was absolutely covered,
basically head to toe, in caked-on mud,
to the point to where the mud had dried
and it was starting to crack,
almost like a desert floor.
Rock hard.
I can only assume that it was involved
in very fast-moving water,
it picked up sediment
from somewhere nearby,
and then it dried out.
So, the first step is removing
pretty much anything
except for the dashboard
and the steering wheel
and the steering column,
because that was a
little bit more involved
than we really had time for.
We're using the vacuum to remove
any residual water in
the back of the trunk.
Going into this detail,
I knew a lot of this vehicle
was going to be sold for parts.
Because there was only X amount made
and only a certain amount
of parts available,
it wouldn't make sense to scrap that car,
especially with so many
parts still being functional.
It changed some of the ways
that we were going to
be cleaning the vehicle
and using some methods
that we wouldn't use in a normal detail.
And we've never done this before,
but we literally took a pressure washer
and sprayed out the whole
interior of the vehicle
in order to remove all the mud.
So, the reason why we wouldn't do that
in a normal detail job is
it would definitely damage
some of the electrical
components of the vehicle
if you didn't give the
car ample time to dry.
So if this was a normal
vehicle that we did that in,
we would have to disconnect the battery
and then make sure that it dried out
for over five or six days.
With a car in this condition,
to clean the carpet was again different
than most vehicles that
we see on a daily basis.
So we probably spent about 45 minutes
just pressure washing gallons of water
into the carpet in order to try and flush
as much mud out of it as possible.
Well, not only that;
we had to flip it over
and spray out mud on the other side.
And then we actually had
to let it drain overnight
to try and dry out as much as we could
before we put it back in the next day
to then continue to
clean it inside the car.
So, once the carpet is dry,
we then place it back into the vehicle
and we use carpet soap.
You spray it onto the carpet,
and then I actually use the extractor
to add more water
in order to create a soapier solution,
and then you agitate it
using a brush that connects to a drill
to release some of the dirt
and grime or the stains
that are contained
within the carpet fibers,
bring them to the top,
so then you can suck it
away with the extractor.
In the extractor we only use water.
If you spray the soap onto the carpet
and if you only have
water in your extractor,
when you see through the
head of the extractor
that there's no more foam,
there's no more bubbles or soap
that's coming out of the carpet,
you know you've not only removed
the contaminants that were in the carpet,
but also any residue from leftover soap.
When we were cleaning the leather,
we had to pressure wash
the majority of the mud
away first in order to
even reveal the leather
to follow a normal type
of detailing method.
There was too much mud on the surface
to really remove it in any other way.
So that's not typically how
we would clean leather seats,
but drastic cases call
for drastic measures.
We then used an all-purpose
cleaner in a Tornador.
It's basically compressed air
that feeds into a reservoir
that holds an all-purpose cleaner,
and then it uses that compressed air
to pick up the solution and blast it into
the material that you're trying to clean.
We'll use it when we know that
the leather has seen a lot of age
and we don't want to
potentially damage it further.
And then I went ahead
and used a leather brush
in order to agitate that further
and to remove as much mud
and sediment as possible.
These would have to dry
for another couple days
in a heated storage facility.
With the exterior, we went ahead
and just did a pretty basic wash.
So we had to make sure that
we just blew out all the mud
from all the cracks and crevices there.
The foam cannon is my
personal favorite part
when it comes to washing
the exterior of a vehicle.
Foam and soap is the same thing.
It's actually like shaving cream.
You spray it onto your hand,
and as you lather it up,
it becomes more foamy.
It helps break down some of the grime,
the grease, the sediment on the vehicle
and then lifts it to the top,
and that way as you're washing,
there's both lubrication as
well as cleaning properties
that help you remove the dirt and grime
as efficiently and safely as possible.
Cleaning the windows,
most people ask what
solution you're using,
what window cleaner are you using,
but in reality,
it's the type of towel that you use
and how many towels you use
and how clean they are.
So, windows are very prone to streaking,
especially when they've
been splattered with mud,
like they were in this vehicle.
So to start out, we just use
your standard shop towels
in order to remove the bulk of the grime,
and then we use another type of towel
that's called GSM.
So it has a higher grams per square meter
of microfiber, and all that means is that
there's more fibers on the towel,
and the more grams per square meter,
the fluffier the towel
and the more microfiber strands there are
to wipe away any of the streaks.
They actually were able to get that car
running again, though.
It still functions, but
with a good conscious,
they can't sell that car to another owner.
When you finish it and you
look back at the result,
we laugh because it's almost like,
I don't know how it came out so well,
but somehow it does.
Narrator: This abandoned
car has layers of debris
after sitting in a barn for 37 years.
My name is Brent Dicesare.
I'm one half of WD Detailing.
And today we're going to be cleaning
a 1978 Sterling Nova that
sat in a barn since 1985.
So, a Sterling Nova is a kit car
which is on a Volkswagen
Beetle chassis and engine.
And it's really unique
because of the way it looks
and the way that the top opens.
There's no doors on this car.
The way that you get in and out
is literally by the whole top lifting up.
We had to take the top off of this car
because it actually couldn't
hold its own weight up
and we didn't want to risk
it falling on one of us.
As soon as we took the top off of the car,
we found this mouse nest right
on the backside of the dash.
It was made out of insulation or carpet
or parts from the seats.
Any random fibers that
they can find in the car
they'll take and make a nest out of.
And then we sanitized the area afterwards
with TriClean, which is a cleaner
that will kill all the bacteria.
Cars attract mice because
they know that it's a dark space,
and when these cars sit in a barn
and nobody's touching them
for 30-plus, 40-plus years,
they're not going to be bothered,
so they're going to
take advantage of that.
And then after that
we were able to take the seats out
and really get in there
and clean everything.
We found that these carpets
were completely disintegrated,
and they're definitely going
to have to replace them.
And we actually haven't really seen
carpets this bad before.
So if I had to make an assumption
on why this happened,
it's a combination of
them sitting over time
and the mice getting into
them and eating them up.
And under the carpet, as
soon as we pulled it out,
I looked down and found a nice surprise
of a dead mouse.
We disposed of it off camera,
but we just had to pick
it up with our gloves
and toss it in the garbage can.
There's no nice way to
throw away a dead mouse.
We started vacuuming the floor pans,
and then we sanitized them
again with our TriClean.
And then we used our steamer behind it
to kill anything else.
And then we wiped it all
away with microfiber towels.
So, this dashboard was
covered in dust completely.
And at this point we're
still using TriClean
to clean the interior,
because we want to disinfect everything.
We knew that this car
isn't going to be started
for quite a while, because it doesn't run
and it needs a lot of repair work,
so if cleaner gets inside the buttons
or inside of the switches,
it's not going to be the end of the world,
because it'll definitely dry up before
there's any kind of electricity
running through this car.
So, if you want to get a barn find,
a good way is searching
on Facebook Marketplace.
The people that we work with
specifically search for these cars,
and then they bring them to us
because they sat for so long.
A lot of it's word of mouth.
So, for these seats, they were covered in
anything that the mice could put on them.
So the first thing that
we do is vacuum them,
and then we'll go ahead and extract them.
So we use our extractor soap,
and then we'll use our drill
brush to agitate the soap
and really work it into those fibers.
And then we'll use our extractor,
which shoots hot water into the fibers
and also sucks it away at the same time.
So it's a vacuum, but
it's a vacuum with water.
The exterior of this
car was covered in dust
from front to back,
and then there was some wood chips
and other stuff in the headlight crevice,
which, I'm pretty sure on this kit,
there's supposed to be a headlight cover,
but for some reason they were missing
on this specific car.
And here we're vacuuming
out some of the jambs,
which we like to do before
we pressure wash off the car,
because if there's any
wood chips or anything,
it might scratch the paint.
So, on the wheels,
they were covered with some
sort of green substance,
which, I don't know if it was mold or not.
And to clean this tire, we'll go ahead
and pressure wash
everything off of it first.
And then we'll use our P&S Brake Buster
on the tire and the rim,
and then we'll use an
assortment of brushes,
usually soft-bristle
brushes and a tire brush.
And then we'll pressure wash it all away.
The paint on this car was
in pretty good condition.
The only thing that we
noticed was deteriorating
was the black paint.
So, what we're spraying on this car
is a paint-safe degreaser
so we can loosen up all that dirt
before we pressure wash it away.
And what that's going to do
is minimize any kind of
swirl marks or scratches.
Paint chips can be damaging to a car,
only because it can cause rust to form
if there's metal underneath
where the paint was.
But there was no rust on this body at all
because it's made out of fiberglass.
So, we're starting to foam the car here
using our pressure washer and foam cannon.
And this is the part that a lot of people
find the most satisfying
in the whole process.
And there's two reasons why
people use foam cannons.
The first one is as a presoak,
so they can loosen up all the dirt
that's on the surface of the car.
But also, instead of just
putting soap in a bucket,
it helps you put soap over the entire car,
which makes the process safer
for the paint and easier.
And after foaming the car,
we'll use microfiber
mitts on the entire car
to wash it down.
And now we're using our Rupes buffer
to take any of the oxidation off
the top layer of the paint,
which will make it a
lot shinier, less dull,
and give it that overall
wow factor at the end.
So this is just, like, a paint correction.
And when it came to the black paint,
we didn't even polish it at all,
because it was starting
to come off of the car
and we didn't want to ruin or take away
any of that paint that was already there.
There wasn't too much that
we could personally do.
It's something that would
have to either be redone
or just left as is.
And after the whole car is cleaned
and we're ready to do
the finishing touches,
we'll do a tire shine.
And as that dries, it leaves the tires
looking nice and matte black,
and it just gives it
that overall wow factor
for the customer.
And the absolute last thing we'll do
is spray a ceramic sealant
over the entire car.
It'll protect the paint just a little bit,
but it'll also give it a nice shine
and just complete the detail.
And that's it.
I was super happy with the
way that this car turned out.
I actually personally
want to buy it myself.
We'll see how that goes
in the near future,
when it's done being fixed up.
When it comes to cleaning barn finds,
if I can give any advice,
it's just to take your time
and really do your research.
That way, you don't make any
super-detrimental mistakes.
Because the last thing you want to do
is find something that has original paint
or an original interior and damage it.
But also, have fun with the process.
Narrator: Next up, this
car has seen better days
as 22 years of mold is deep cleaned.
Hi, my name is Brent Dicesare,
I'm one half of WD Detailing,
and today we're going to be cleaning
a really moldy Buick Reatta
that sat outside for over 22 years.
The owner took me into his backyard,
and as soon as I saw
this one specifically,
I knew we had to do it.
When we opened the doors, the first thing
that we found was a ton of mold
and what looks like a mouse nest
beginning to form at some point.
All in all, this car smelled
absolutely horrendous,
and it was just disgusting.
So, the first thing that we're doing
is working on the engine bay,
and that means getting rid of
all of the leaves and
anything that piled up
over the years in the jamb of the bay.
After that, we went ahead and we used
a pressure washer and
some degreaser on it.
And after we finish the engine bay,
we moved on to the wheels.
So, when cleaning the wheels,
the first thing we'll do
is pressure wash them off,
just to get a cleaner surface.
And then we'll spray our
wheel and tire cleaner on them
and use a couple different brushes
to get into the wheel crevices
and on the face of the rim
and then behind the rim and in the barrel.
Then, after that, we'll
spray everything away,
leaving a really clean wheel.
Now we're getting ready to pressure wash
and clean the outside of the car.
We wanted to use our
paint-safe degreaser first
to loosen up all that mold and grime
before we actually took a
pressure washer to the surface.
And then we started pressure washing,
which is by far the most satisfying part
of any detail that we do.
So, our process with pressure washing,
we always like to try to
work from top to bottom.
So the first thing we did was the roof.
So we went to the hood after that,
and then the sides,
and then the rear.
Just watching the pressure
washer go in straight lines,
taking away those years of grime,
just feels so good inside.
I can't even explain it.
And then, after having all
that pressure washed off,
we'll go ahead and spray
the entire car down
with our foam cannon.
So, here we're using the foam cannon,
and the reason for that is because
after pressure washing the car,
there is still grime and dirt left
on the surface of the paint,
and the foam cannon really
just helps add more soap
to the paint than putting
soap in a bucket would.
And when you're washing the car off
with microfiber mitts,
it makes it easier to do, and quicker.
After we wash it off, we
spray the ceramic spray,
just to give it some protection
before moving on to the interior.
So, in our first round of vacuuming,
we knew that this car was really bad,
so we weren't going to get everything.
So we definitely were going to need to use
the drill brush and extractor later on.
This area looks like mice made a nest,
and they were both leaving
their droppings behind
and also bringing some
food or different materials
from the inside of the
car that they could find.
We were able to vacuum that up
and actually get it pretty clean.
So, when we work on
doors that have leather
or vinyl or anything like that,
we're pretty much using the same process,
especially when they're covered in mold.
The first thing we'll do is use Tri-Clean,
which is a cleaner that
kills 99.9% of bacteria,
and then we'll use soft-bristle brushes
and sometimes a steamer from a distance,
just to kill the bacteria
and kill the mold,
and then we'll wipe it away.
And we'll spend a decent amount of time
on each section of the car
to make sure that we really get it clean
before moving on to the next one.
We repeat the process with the steamer
and the Tri-Clean throughout
the entire interior,
including the steering wheel,
which was covered in a
very thick layer of mold,
worse than any steering
wheel we've ever seen.
So, what we're using is the Tornador,
and that's pressurized air,
and it's using it to dry it off
and also blow out any
product that could be
in the cracks or anything like that.
Older leather can definitely
be tougher to work with,
because if mold sits
on it for a long time,
it can damage it, it can remove the dye,
and you also have to be really
careful with the steamer,
because if you spend too
much time in one area
or you get too close, it
can definitely damage it.
And after we clean the
interior components,
we'll go ahead and focus on the carpets,
and the first thing we'll do
is spray our extractor
soap into the carpet
and we'll get it wet,
and then we'll use the drill brush
to agitate it into the
fibers of the carpet
to help release any stains
or any dirt that's in there.
And then we'll use the
extractor to suck that all away.
And after the interior's completely clean
with the leather and the
vinyl, anything like that,
we'll go ahead and use
a leather conditioner.
That way, it can bring back the softness
and the suppleness,
but it also leaves it with a nice shine.
And then some of the
final things that we do
to the car is cleaning the windows,
and we add a tire shine
to give the car those finishing touches,
so when the owner actually sees it,
it gives that wow factor.
All in all, this detail probably took us
around 12 hours over
the course of one day.
And just looking over the
final result of the car,
we couldn't have been happier
with the way it turned out.
Even though there was some damage
to the exterior with the paint,
everything else absolutely was fantastic.
Narrator: Andreas Yurich
from WorkShop Rebuild
shares how he uses a laser
to remove years of rust from this old car.
Hi. My name's Andreas Yurich.
On social media, I go by Workshop Rebuild,
and today I'll be sharing with you guys
the laser-cleaning process.
And I will be cleaning 40 years of rust
on a classic car from 1979.
Laser cleaning is a
process where a laser beam
gets emitted from a
laser-cleaning machine.
And this handheld device
will always be pointed
towards a metal surface with
any surface contaminants.
If you have parts that come in
that are just full of grease, full of oil,
just full of any surface contamination,
you can actually use this
laser-cleaning process
to remove all of that.
Looking at the Renault R5, Le Car,
the bodywork is still very straight,
but around the edges,
it does have some rust.
And especially on the underside
or around the wheel wells,
you will see quite a bit of rust.
And I would like to remove that,
so I can bring this car
back to running conditions
and also make it somehow
suitable for the road.
The first step is just really
visually looking at everything.
It's really important to know
where the rust is building up
and which direction it's going in
to actually address it
with the laser cleaner.
The next step is actually just
to prepare the laser-cleaning machine.
Once I have all the settings set up,
I will put on my protective gear.
So I will be wearing a mask,
and I will be wearing
laser-protective glasses,
just to be safe.
After that, I grab the handheld gun,
and I get to work.
And I started off with the wheels.
I'm taking away quite a bit of rust,
and that's been built up
for over 40 years, right?
So, the most outer parts of the car
I wanted to clean first,
and I was going to work my way in.
That was just my thought process.
Can be in any other order,
but that's just the way I do things.
After the wheels were clean,
I did the fenders themselves.
Right around the fenders it rusts,
because you have, all the time,
water splashing up on the fender.
And that's where it will rust,
because the water
actually doesn't evaporate
or go away, it just
hides behind the fender.
Once I was done with the fenders,
I moved in to the wheel hubs.
It cleaned up the rust very well.
I was really surprised that
it cleaned up everything.
Cleaned up the threads
on the hubs themselves.
So, how does laser cleaning actually work?
So the laser-cleaning machine
has a certain frequency.
Once its frequency is established
within the laser source,
that will be emitted
through the handheld gun.
Once it's pointed at your work piece,
it will resonate with the contamination
on top of the metal surface.
The metal surface is the last resort.
That will not absorb any light.
So everything above the metal surface
will actually absorb the light
of the laser-cleaning machine.
Once it touches anything above the metal,
the heat will actually
remove the contamination
on top of the metal.
Either that, if it's not
the pressure or the heat,
the laser beam itself will
vaporize the substance on top, right?
So it's either or, right?
And that happens within
milliseconds. Nanoseconds. So.
With any laser-cleaning machine,
this is a beam of light,
and it also creates a lot of heat.
You can damage the surface substrate,
which is the metal.
So you always want to keep your tool
or your handheld gun in motion.
You do not want to keep it too long
at one certain area or on one spot
because you can damage the metal
if you keep it on one spot for too long.
Once I finished up with the wheel hubs,
I actually moved on to the muffler.
That was on the other side.
There are exactly four
settings on this machine
that I can manipulate.
So, the first setting is power.
The second setting is frequency.
The third setting is the speed
of the laser beam itself,
and the fourth setting is
the width of the laser beam.
So with all these settings,
I can vary or adjust the laser beam.
So if I'm cleaning aluminum,
I will bring the settings
a little bit down,
because aluminum is softer
and it also has a lower
melting temperature.
For steel, I go up in the settings,
and usually I run them at around 80%,
and aluminum I run at 60%.
I really noticed along the body panels,
I have to be very delicate.
I had to bring down the
values a little bit.
Because that metal is so thin,
I just had to keep it in
movement all the time.
And lastly, I ended up around the engine,
where some components
were already missing,
but I obviously cleaned up
the inside of the engine.
So, you can see the before and after
on all four cylinders.
The cylinders cleaned up very well.
The cylinder head, the intake manifold,
and the exhaust manifold were removed
from the car previously,
so I could clean them up on the bench.
And cleaning them up on the bench
actually gives me the opportunity
to clean them all the way around,
which makes it super easy.
And the final finish also shows
that it's a much better way
to clean them on the bench.
What's really nice about it
is that you do not damage the substrate,
which is the metal surface.
So if you're working on machined areas,
like internal components for an engine,
anything around any bodywork
for a very, very delicate
restoration project,
or even something historical,
you do not want to damage that substrate.
So that's where laser cleaning comes in.
So, the technology behind laser cleaning
is evolving very fast.
A lot of companies or manufacturers
are starting to hook these up to robots
and to their production lines.
Even after something is manufactured,
in any industry, there
is still some residue,
debris, or something
that has to be removed
for a further process.
So when I look at the
final result of this car,
from front to back or outside to in,
I'm really happy and
satisfied with the finish.
The body panels cleaned up very well.
It removed all the paint.
It removed all the primer.
It even removed some of the rust
that was actually even chipping away.
And towards the front of the engine,
where I have aluminum parts,
it just cleaned that perfect,
without any issues and
without any thermal damage.
I was really happy with everything,
and now I can continue on
with my rebuild process.
Since this technology is really new,
I'm still learning as I'm going,
so I'm not a true professional just yet,
but I'm learning every day.
I'm really into this new technology,
and I can't wait for this technology
to get better in the near future.
Narrator: Dryce Nation
takes it one step further
with the latest detailing
technology, dry ice.
It's Scott Ales with Dryce Nation.
So, today I'd like to show you
the step-by-step process
that we go through in dry-ice cleaning.
So, there's a number of things
that are unique about dry-ice cleaning.
No. 1, we're not using water,
so when we're done, we're
not cleaning up water spots,
we're not trying to dry things.
If you can see the dirt, we can clean it.
So there's a lot of places
where you might be able to see that dirt
but you can't physically get to it
with any tools or brushes or devices,
and we can.
We can clean that in the
deep recesses of your car
that you might not have
been able to before.
It's like when the car
rolled off the factory line.
You've cleaned it back to that condition.
So, when we're just getting started,
we're trying to identify the method
of what we're going to attack first.
When we put a car on the lift,
we always want to make sure
and pull the wheels off
so we can inspect the
inner wheelhouse area.
We use a torque wrench to
break the lug nuts loose.
We also like to consider,
depending on the customer,
if they want us to remove
the inner wheelhouse liners,
which are typically plastic,
to see if they want us
to clean behind there.
So once we have the car on
the lift and we're prepped,
we're then moving our attention
toward the compressed-air system
to make sure that we've got
all of our drying and cleaning systems
for the air system in order,
and then we're going to load the machine
with the dry ice
so that we're prepared to blast.
And so the first thing we try to do
is try to get the wheels out of the way.
We have four wheels, and we'll just
take those one at a time.
We'll look for tar,
we'll look for adhesion,
remnants from old wheel weights,
which are totally a pain to remove,
and we make that pretty easy.
And then we'll just clean
the wheels inside and out.
The three settings are,
you've got pressure,
which is psi that you're
all familiar with;
there's pounds per minute;
and then you've got size of particle.
So those are the three
things that you can adjust.
But for the first time
we can actually choose
the size of the particle,
so it enables us to be
able do delicate things
in the same area of things
that might be aggressive.
Previously you were putting
those delicate items at risk
with the large particle size.
When we're starting the project,
we're always looking for
the dirtiest area first.
We like to get the hard
stuff out of the way,
so that when we get to those
surfaces or those coatings
that we're trying to remove that are easy,
then it makes everything go smoother
because you're not double cleaning.
So, you'll notice as I'm cleaning
that the gun is never static.
It's always moving.
It's always constantly moving.
And the reason for that is we have
the risk of a concentrated -109 degrees
on a particular substrate
or part of the car
that you could damage in one spot.
So, I'd like to take a minute
and explain how this actually works.
There's really three
things that are occurring.
You've got kinetic energy,
which is driven by the
psi of the air system.
You've got cold temperature, -109 degree,
that causes things to shrink
so they lose adhesion.
And then you've got the
actual thermal expansion
of a solid chemical going to a gas,
so that's 800 times its
original solid size.
Those three things work very well together
to remove this dirt in a way
that you've probably never seen before.
There's a lot of technique
opportunity here, right?
'Cause in a sense,
this is a bit of an artist's effort
at an industrial job, if you will.
I've found it to be helpful for me
to function in a circular pattern
so that I never have any hard lines.
The circular pattern gives me the control
that I feel comfortable with.
There's really nothing that's more fun
in this process than doing bare aluminum.
You really can't hurt bare aluminum,
and so in that case, you can crank it up,
it's more efficient, you
feel better about it,
and it's very satisfying to the eye.
So, once we've removed
those really difficult grimy surfaces,
we do move into a combination of handwork
and fine-detail dry-ice cleaning.
People presume that what we're doing
is a magic wand
and we just wave it once and we're done,
and that's not true.
When we have surface rust,
we do integrate a fair amount of handwork.
Whether it be all-purpose cleaners,
white erasers, Ospho, 0000 steel wool,
definitely we do use handwork.
At the point in time that we believe
we're finished with the underside,
we'll bring the car
down three or four feet,
and then we'll look at
the top of the suspension
and the wheelhouse areas
and then we'll notice,
"OK, we've got some more work to do here."
So once we've cleaned
the underside of the car,
we bring the car down on the lift,
and we have an extra-wide lift
so that we can open the doors,
get the floor mats out,
we can do the interior vents,
the door jams, the engine bay, the trim.
And we don't abrade the surface,
and we'll do what takes somebody
two hours in 10 minutes.
So, we were fortunate enough
to receive this '55 Porsche Speedster,
and it literally is a barn find.
What you're seeing here
is me trying to see
if I can remove this crazy-thick mold
that's 30, 40 years old
off 60-year-old vinyl.
That mold was so thick it
would stop your fingernail.
This was a big moment for us,
and the end result is
we will apply some all-purpose
cleaner at the end.
and we'll wipe off the
final film from this panel.
But it just turns out spectacular.
So, we don't add to or remove any CO2
from the environment, so we're neutral.
And we don't use water, which means
that we don't rinse chemicals down a drain
into any sewer systems
or into drain fields.
So from an environmental standpoint,
by far it is absolutely
a better cleaning solution
than using water and chemicals.
The dry-ice-cleaning world
could be considered the
highest-level OCD crowd.
Think about the underside of a car
and the intricacies of every component.
There's a lot of surface area
to all of these parts and pieces.
Don't think that it's going to be easy,
but the satisfaction factor
for those that care about the way
their assets or their artifacts look
is at the highest level.
So it's worth the energy.
Narrator: Gabe Tyler from GT Detailing
takes us behind the scenes
of reviving this car
filled with trash.
The detail started by removing
the stained seats and floor mats.
Gabe evaluates whether the
seats need to be removed,
depending on any stains under the seat
and between the center console.
Once the floor was exposed,
Gabe separated the trash and
customer's personal belongings,
using his hand to remove the bigger items
and a vacuum to clean
up any leftover trash.
He cleaned the door jambs
with a degreaser and brush,
followed by a power washer
to remove any dirt or gunk.
This step is done early
in the detailing process
and before shampooing, in case
water sprays on the carpet.
A vacuum removed as much
dirt and junk as possible
from around the car,
including the floor, seats,
and under the spare tire cover.
After vacuuming, Gabe started
the chemical cleaning process,
working from the top down
to avoid double cleaning
due to chemicals and soap dripping down.
[Spray hisses]
To remove stains on the headliner,
he used the spray, drill brush,
and a microfiber towel.
He deep-cleaned the floor mats
with the pressure washer and shampoo,
and then hung them to dry.
To restore the seats,
Gabe used a steam cleaner,
dry brush, and extractor
to remove any stains.
He prefers to use McCulloch steamers
because there are multiple
attachments to choose from.
Moving to the carpet, Gabe
sprayed a carpet cleaner
and used an agitator to
bring any hidden dirt
to the surface, sucking it
up with a Mytee extractor.
He steam cleaned the steering wheel
and pedals with a brush attachment.
Steam cleaners help
remelt dried, melted gunk
like candy and chocolate,
for an easier removal.
He treated the door panels
with a vacuum, spray,
steam cleaner, and microfiber towel.
For plastic surfaces, Gabe
works in small sections
to ensure he doesn't miss any spots.
Once the plastic surfaces were clean,
he applied a plastic UV protector.
Gabe reinstalled the seats
and floor mats into the car,
and cleaned the glass,
And the detailing was complete.
Narrator: Larry Kosilla
shares the importance
of keeping your car clean
and how to prevent
water damage from leaks.
Hey, I'm Larry Kosilla from AmmoNYC.com.
We manufacture car-cleaning supplies.
Today, I'm gonna show you
the step-by-step process
for cleaning one of the
most disgusting cars
I've ever worked on.
Right off the bat, I'm saying
there's a water leak somewhere.
There's obviously mice.
This particular case, it smelled so bad.
There's urine from mice in there.
This is kind of the next level,
where you're cleaning it just to make it
so that you can safely
operate the vehicle.
On cases like this, when
there's lots of mold,
lots of junk,
I increase the water temperature
as much as the power washer can handle,
and that'll increase the cleaning ability.
When you hit it with water,
it's gonna indicate where
there might be a leak.
There's seals, what they call rails
or rain guards or rain rails.
If those get packed or compacted with,
you can see in the door jams,
muck and gunk and grime and leaves,
it actually backs up and overflows
and then flows into the vehicle.
The debris in the door jams were 100%
the cause for the water.
Basically the water pools on the bottom,
underneath the carpet.
I use a tiny little brush
to kinda get in there.
The idea is to lift a
lot of the door seals
and get underneath the door seals,
because if they're not
perfectly flush, again,
that whole rain issue as the door closes.
And if there's leaves and junk in there,
it just won't seal properly.
So, in terms of buffing
or restoring the paint,
this mission was to use
a microfiber cutting pad.
I used a compound.
And what that microfiber pad does
is it kind of tickles the surface
of the paint, so to speak.
And it removes a lot of the stuff
that just didn't come out with a wash.
And if it's embedded in
the pores of the paint,
just like a blackhead, so to speak,
I have to go in there and just
remove all of that, exfoliate it.
As the vibration, or what we call
oscillation of the machine, "zzz,"
as it's buzzing, it's actually vibrating
a lot of the dirt that's behind
the headlights and the taillights
and all these little pieces.
So, in this case,
I washed the car for a second time
after I buffed it,
then, afterwards, you
wanna protect it again.
So, in this case, we use a product
called AMMO Reflex Pro,
which is a type of coating.
It's an antimicrobial,
which is perfect for this car,
because obviously there's mold
and bacteria all over the place.
When it comes to headlights,
as the sun is penetrating the headlight,
it's just chewing up all
the UV protection it has.
And over time, it sort
of just decays, right?
It becomes dead skin on top.
So what we need to do is
remove that dead skin.
Then you can go in just like the paint,
with a microfiber cutting pad,
an abrasive, like a compound,
use your pad, polish it up.
And you can see within a minute or two,
it'll rejuvenate that.
Now you have to put the suntan lotion on.
And in this case, you
wanna re-clear-coat it.
With respect to windows,
the best way that I've
found over the years,
and this is an evolving process,
is, first, use a little
bit of window cleaner.
You spray it down.
First thing is use a scrub pad.
That scrub pad is gonna
lift a lot of the oils
and junk that are stuck
to the glass over time.
And so as you do that,
it's still gonna be wet and kinda gross.
You take what we call towel No. 1,
and you scoop up all of that oily residue.
It's not gonna look pretty at this point,
and that's totally fine.
So, once it's kind of dry,
then you go back in,
lubricate again with a glass cleaner,
and then use a squeegee,
working top to bottom for obvious reasons.
And then you go in with a separate towel
called No. 2 towel, and
you can wipe it down.
And sometimes they call them glass towels.
Then you can really go
in and buff the edges.
So it's this constant
running after smears.
When we're vacuuming the inside of a car,
first thing you wanna look at is the size
of the debris that you're
trying to vacuum up.
And then first thing is sort
of vacuum up the big parts.
Then I put in what's
called a crevice tool.
A crevice tool sort of
looks like your hand.
It's very narrow.
You remove a lot more debris that way,
because the orifice is much smaller,
thus the lifting power is much better.
With respect to shampooing,
you can use a scrub,
a red-handle scrub brush,
they're $2 or whatever.
They're everywhere.
In this case, we used AMMO Shag,
which is a cleaner just for fibers,
carpets, Alcantara,
seats, that kinda thing.
And then the goal is to
agitate the junk to the surface
and then wet vac it out.
I thought I had already sucked up
a lot of the poo and all that stuff,
but as I was shampooing,
you could actually see
little bits of mouse poo
in the shampoo machine, which is insane.
That means mouse poo
was not only on top of the surface,
but underneath.
So, when you remove certain
parts of the vehicle,
like carpets or the rear trunks,
you can pull that out and shampoo it.
That's way better,
because there's just compressed water
shooting out all the junk.
It's way better than just sitting there
and going back and forth.
But it makes sense, you can't do that to,
let's say, the carpets
underneath the seats,
you're not gonna do that.
OK, so to clean the interior,
we use a couple of different tools.
We use AMMO Lather.
That is designed for
plastic, leather, and vinyl.
And then we use an interior scrub brush.
It's really good for buttons and things.
And then we use a scrub pad.
Now, the scrub pad basically takes
that top layer of junk off
before you come in with
a microfiber towel.
Then, once you're all
done in your scrubbing,
'cause what you're doing is
you're agitating the dirt,
it comes to the surface,
what we call a lather,
and then you scoop away that junk.
Once everything is done,
you take compressed air, blow them out,
and as the lather sort of squeaks out
from underneath and the sides,
just scoop it up with a microfiber towel.
Let it dry, assess the situation,
then you can go back in
any spots you've missed.
The separation between a regular detail
and an amazing detail is
usually the last, like,
3, 4, 5%.
So, you have silver from the car,
and then you have this
kind of faded, whitish,
gross material or trim,
you wanna brighten that up.
So, I took the pad and applied mud.
And, again, it's to draw this contrast.
Even if you're not a car person,
even if you're not excited
about washing your car,
there is a level of cleanliness
that actually translates into dollars,
into saving your investment in this case.
You have to keep those
seals clean at the very minimum,
especially if you park outside.